Don't forget to wear
a jacket, or you're
going to catch a
cold-- or will you?
Hey, friends, Laci Green here.
Ai, ai, ai, it's that
time of year again.
Everyone's getting sick,
including me, sadly,
still getting over a
little something something.
On Facebook, our "D News"
friend Kristi Jimerson asks,
could you guys do a video on why
we get sick in the winter more
than summer?
I've done some
research, and there
doesn't seem to be
any definitive answers
and I'm really curious now.
Me too, Kristi, me too.
It's conventional
wisdom that people
tend to get sick more
during the colder months.
In fact, the word "influenza"
comes from the aged
Italian phrase,
"influenza di freddo,"
or "influence of the cold."
There's an odd conundrum
here, because scientists
have found again and again
that being in the cold
doesn't actually make us sick
or more prone to getting sick.
So that part is just a myth.
Even when we're shivering,
our core body temperature
stays the same.
This is thanks to the
magic of homeostasis.
So if it's not the cold that's
making us sick, what is it?
The explanation
scientists have to offer
is that when it's cold outside,
people are crowded indoors.
All throughout the year at any
given time, a few people around
you are infected with some
kind of contagious viruses
or bacteria, even though they
may not have any symptoms.
But in the winter, we're in
closer contact with them,
which makes it infinitely easier
for those bacteria and viruses
to hop from person to person.
We're also in closed
air systems inside,
so airborne circulate
through our homes, offices,
and schools, which brings me
to my second perpetrator--
schools, or more
specifically, germy, sneezy,
snot-nosed children.
A huge study at the
University of Warwick
pegged children as the top
spreaders of infection.
It's because they
have the highest
number of daily social contacts.
Children go back to school,
then they're kept indoors,
with their germy peers right
around the cold season.
So they infect each
other, and then
they infect their parents,
who infect their coworkers.
And before you know it, the
whole freaking world is sick.
The last contributing
factor pertains to the flu
specifically.
Different microbes
and viruses all
survive and transmit at
different temperatures.
And for the flu, it
transmits into cold.
At 41 degrees Fahrenheit,
the flu virus is most stable.
It's ready to infect
you and wreak havoc
on your body and life.
But as it becomes warmer, it's
harder and harder for the virus
to transmit.
In fact, once the
temperature hits 86 degrees,
the flu virus can't be
transmitted anymore.
So there you go-- the key to
avoid getting sick this winter
is to avoid all contact
with other human beings.
Just stay in your basement
this holiday season,
like the good little internet
citizen that you are.
Or maybe just head off to your
own private tropical island.
Thanks for joining
me for "D News."
Hope this helped answer
your question, Kristi.
If you folks have any other
video topics you'd like to see,
let me down below on,
or on Twitter at D News.
And we'll check them out.
Bye, bye.